vous savez pourquoi j'ai un petit
sourire en coin que je me frotte les
mains là comme un méchant dans un film
parce que vous l'attendiez cette vidéo
qu'est ce que vous l'attendez et vous
êtes gâtés cinq histoires au lieu de
trois et c'est même pas une vidéo
spéciale halloween la vidéo spéciale
halloween h dirigea les avis paru il ya
un peu de tout aujourd'hui mais il ya
aussi des nouvelles mécaniques je vais
le raconter dans un ordre un peu au pif
je me suis pas dit qu'elle est la plus
intéressante à raconter en premier en
deuxième ces foules random mais ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui chacun
d'entre vous va au moins adoré deux de
ces histoires tellement les mécaniques
sont différentes les unes des autres y
en a pour tout le monde je rappelle pour
ceux qui ont pas vu la vidéo d'annoncé
on lance une bd serait d'horreur c'est
trois histoires originales pour ceux qui
n'ont pas encore précommander le lien
dans la description et vous avez déjà
été très nombreux à la précommande est
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup ça me fait
très plaisir c'est faux puisque la vidéo
d'annoncé des prix comme on n'est pas
encore sorti ou mange ton ce serait
d'horreur je spécule j'ai peur comme les
gens dont les histoires je vous
racontais maintenant tout le monde est
prêt on passe aux histoires et la
première c'est celle de mirriah
l'histoire que nous raconte myriam a eu
lieu récemment puisque ça s'est passé en
2020 myriam à 23 ans elle est belge et
ses parents sont divorcés ça a son
importance puisque elle explique qu'elle
vit chez sa mère mais que son père a une
grande maison constituée d'une cave ce
que j'appellerais plutôt un sous-sol vu
qu'il ya une cuisine et un salon dans
cette cave un rez-de-chaussée et un
étage ça a son importance dans la suite
de l'histoire en août 2020 la meilleure
amie de myriam se marient et myriam en
tant que meilleur ami vous connaissez
est chargée d'organiser l'enterrement de
vie de jeune fille elle organise donc un
petit week-end de rêve pour sa meilleure
pote et ses copines spa reste aux
activités sportives et pyjama party les
activités de la journée étant payantes
elles ont plus de budget pour louer
airbnb pour le soir mais c'est pas grave
myriam à une soluce elles vont faire la
pige à ma partie dans la maison de son
père elle s'arrange évidemment avec lui
pour qu'il soit pas là le soir de la
fugea ma partie et le samedi soir elle
débarque à neuf chez lui prête à faire
la fête la fête commence l'ambiance est
au max est l'une des copines de myriam
là prévient que son copain va passer la
voir aux alentours de 22 heures en bas
de la maison du père de myriam myriam
lui dis bah écoute pas tout si tu sais
quoi je te file la clé de la maison
comme ça qu'on a fini de voir ton gars
devant la maison tu peux rentrer quand
tu veux aux alentours de 22 heures la
copine de myriam descend donc les
escaliers essor et s'absente pendant
plusieurs minutes avant de revenir et de
remercier myriam de lui a refilé la clé
est d'avoir laissé voir son mec la
soirée continue monde s'amuse et aux
alentours de 23 heures une autre copine
de merian lui demande un petit service
décidément c'est le problème d'organiser
des soirées chez toi c'est que c'était
le référent elle lui explique juste
qu'elle veut aller fumer une clope et
elle demande donc à myriam de la
compagnie et c'est là que la soirée
prend une tournure un peu roule myriam
et sa pote fumeuse descendent au
rez-de-chaussée de chez elle et lorsqu
elle s'apprête à aller sur le palier
elle constate que la porte d'entrée est
restée ouverte myriam comprend tout de
suite d'où ça vient c'est clairement sa
pote qui allait voir son mec juste avant
qu'un mal fermé la porte en rentrant
dans la maison mais bon elle explique
qu'elle vit dans un quartier très calme
et que ça m'inquiète pas plus que ça en
revanche à l'intérieur de la maison
juste à côté de la porte d'entrée se
trouve la porte qui mène à la cave enfin
moi j'appelle ça le sous-sol vu qu'à une
cuisine en salle comme la soirée se
passe à les tâches dans le salon avec
mejia mais n'a pas envie de tout le
monde ce split dans la maison de son
père elle décide et intuitivement au cas
où de verrouiller la porte de la cave
elle va ensuite avec sa pote fumer une
clope comme prévu et a pris quelques
minutes elle entend des coups comme si
quelqu'un frapper contre un mur ou une
porte et myriam au moment où elle en
train de demander aux filiales étages
sis est l'une d'entre elles qui a fait
ce bruit elle voit un truc bouger et ce
truc c'est les clés accroché à la porte
de la cave des clés posé sur une porte
globalement ça ne bouge pas tout seul
myriam et sa pote courra les tâches pour
prévenir tout le reste des filles et
quelques minutes plus tard tout le monde
est au rez de chaussée devant la porte
de la cave à réfléchir est ce qu'il faut
faire décision pas facile à prendre mais
en même temps c'est un peu l'unique
chose à faire dans cette situation les 9
décembre au sous sol une fois en bas
elle allume la lumière il ya le salon et
la cuisine mais y'a personne myriam et
sa pote fumeux sont rassurés le reste du
groupe et soûlé puisqu'il a crevé une
grosse cassure dans l'ambiance de
l'enterrement de vie de jeune fille de
sa meilleur pote ed façon après avoir vu
qu'il ya personne dans le sous-sol bombe
à la fête reprend tout le monde remonte
et à partir de là il va rien se passer
de blizzard jusqu'au lendemain le
lendemain tout le monde est en gueule de
bois d'accord classique elles prennent
tout un petit déjeuner ensemble mais
pour ça il faut du café et la machine à
café et dans la cuisine au sous sol
myriam descend la chercher et en
remontant au rez de chaussée comme à
l'aller main prise elle ne verrouille
pas la porte de la cave derrière elle le
petit déjeuner commencer puis petit à
petit la maison ce vide les filles
rentrent chez elles une à une jusqu'à ce
que myriam se retrouve tout seul dans la
maison une fois seul dans la maison
évidemment elle repense à ces trois
bruit de la veille elle repense aux clés
qui bougeait sur la porte elle sait pas
trop pourquoi mais elle est convaincue à
ce moment là qu'il faut pas qu'elle
retourne dans la cave de la journée aux
alentours de 17 heures le grand ménage
est terminée myriam évidemment est
fatiguée et elle s'endort sur le canapé
du salon elle se réveille une heure et
demie plus tard mais elle se réveille en
sueur lé mal est sais pas pourquoi mais
les mâles et elle a peur quoi d'être
seul dans cette maison ce qui est celle
où elle se lève elle récupère que la
moitié de ses affaires et elle site de
quitter sur le champ la maison avant de
partir elle fait quand même une petite
d'anglais et c'est ce truc qu'on fait
pour se rassurer quand on a une
sensation mais que notre côté rationnel
nous dit mais non tu rigoles à haute
voix tout seul dans la maison elle va
dire s il ya quelqu un il ya du gâteau à
l'état n'hésite pas à te servira à et
elle se barre personnellement je
comprends ce beauf on est dimanche une
fois l'arrêt bus elle attend plusieurs
dizaines de minutes qui passent ya pas
beaucoup de buts mais ça y est enfin
assise dans le bus direction chez sa
mère elle a plus de mauvais feeling mais
le bus sur le chemin il passe devant la
maison de son père et c'est là que son
coeur va s'arrêter parce que quand elle
regarde la maison de son père elle voit
une silhouette à travers la fenêtre de
sa main et immédiatement elle relie tous
les éléments ce qui s'est passé la
veille son mauvais feeling est seul dans
la maison tout cet enchaînement de
choses un peu relou et elle décide
d'appeler son père immédiatement pour le
prévenir et devinez la suite en arrivant
sur place le père de myriam découvre que
la porte de la véranda est grande
ouverte sur la grande table de la
cuisine se trouve à lille y ait des
couteaux de cuisine est aussi le
sécateur à les tâches dans le salon il
restait bel et bien un gâteau et devinez
quoi une barre a été découpé et manger y
avait donc depuis le début bel et bien
quelqu'un qui était rentré dans la
maison entre le moment où la peau de
myriam revenait d' après avoir vu son
mec et le moment où myriam est sorti
pour fumer une clope avec sa pote en
revanche comment se fait-il que quand
les neuf filles soit allé dans la cave
elle ne l'est pas vu mais rien mais elle
sait toujours pas où ils étaient cachés
mais le mec était forcément là elle l'a
probablement senti dans son sommeil ou
quoi et c'est pour ça qu'elle s'est
réveillée vraiment mode bouffées de
chaleur trop mal bien entendu elle se
demande ce qui se serait passé ce soir
là si avec sa porte elle avait décidé
d'ouvrir tout de suite la porte de la
cave après avoir entendu les toc toc toc
c'est la fin de l'histoire de myriam
allez vous interdira beaucoup plus
d'aller voir leurs mecs devant la maison
oui en fait je trouve ça ou dans cette
histoire que le mec se soit fait enfermé
dans la maison et qu'il ait passé la
nuit là bas en fait je trouve ça
horrible la deuxième histoire c'est
celle de scott elle est vachement
originale parce que c'est une histoire
de garde forestier oui en gros il est
posé dans une tour d'observation géante
au milieu d'un parc national il balaye
l'horizon avec des jumelles à la
recherche des signes d'un départ
d'incendié il est pas tout seul il a un
collègue situé à 8 km de lui dans une
autre tour d'observation un jour scott
tombe sur un piège à ours illégal alors
le braconnage bien entendu est illégal
dans le parc donc ce piège à ours n'a
rien à faire là mais même si c'est
passible de lourdes amendes même de
peines d'emprisonnement il ya quand même
des gens qui viennent dans la réserve et
qui essayent quelques minutes après
avoir découvert ce piège scott entend
des tirs immédiatement il retourne dans
sa tour à son poste d'observation et il
prend son fusil à lunette il explique
qu'il a un fusil parce que quelques mois
plus tôt un de ses collègues observateur
s'est fait mutiler à mort par un grizzly
et après ça évidemment les autorités ont
équipé chaque tour d'observation d'un
fusil de précision et tout d'un coup il
entend le grondement d'un camion alors
rien d'alarmant dans un premier temps
parce qu'il ya souvent ben son pote tu
gardes forestiers situés dans une tour à
8 km qui lui rend visite dans sa jeep
pour boire un soda avec lui scott prend
ses jumelles ils les pointes en
direction du grondement du camion sauf
que là il voit pas ben ils voient quatre
hommes armés sortir du camion et
commençait à poser des pièges à ours
partout autour d'eux immédiatement scott
prend son fusil descendre sa tour
d'observation et marche en direction des
4 marne il explique qu'à l'époque il a
21 ans il est hyper naïf il a jamais
rien vécu de tel et à cause de son
manque d'expérience il n'a pas le
réflexe d'appeler les autres angels dont
ben il se dit qu'il va pouvoir gérer la
situation tout seul en arrivant sur
place il a à peine le temps de leur
adresser la parole qui se prend un
uppercut quand il revient lui-même il a
plu larmes dans sa main il a à peine le
temps de réaliser ce qui se passe qu'il
est désarmé et qui se reprend un coup
cette fois dans le ventre bref les
quatre mecs face à lui ne rigole pas du
tout scott est désemparé il sait pas
quoi faire il a jamais fait face à une
situation pareille les hommes face à lui
vont le prendre et vont commencer à le
traîner sur plusieurs centaines de
mètres avant d'être mis à genoux par les
quatre personnages ce qu'on réalise que
sa position c'est celle carmet cas avant
de se faire exécuter par une arme à feu
alors il fait le seul truc qui lui reste
à faire c'est à dire fermez les yeux et
prier et quelques secondes plus tard il
entend ce qu'ils redoutaient tant à
savoir un coup de feu
il entend un coup de feu mais il est
toujours en vie et puis quelques
secondes plus tard il entend des
gyrophares et après les gyrophares c'est
la voix de ben qui longtemps et ce soir
là ben lui a sauvé la vie en fait
quelques minutes plus tôt quand scott en
temps le moteur d'un camion benne
l'entend aussi sauf que ben lui suit la
procédure et médiatement il prend son
talkie walkie et ils essaient de
communiquer avec scott sauf qu'à ce
moment-là scott est déjà descendu de sa
tour comme scott répond pas ben monte
dans sa voiture et se dirige à 300 à
l'heure vers latour de ben se rend à la
tour d'observation de scott et voit
qu'il est bel et bien plus là il
prévient immédiatement tous les rangers
et tous les rangers se met à chercher
aux alentours de la tour d'observation
de scott et heureusement il on tombait
sur scott au bon moment parce que
clairement quelques secondes plus tard
scott était mort et ils ont procédé à
l'arrestation des quatre braconniers ont
littéralement fini en prison ben a
reconduit scott à sa tour d'observation
en leur assurant comme un grand frère et
pas du tout en lui reprochant de ne pas
l'avoir prévenue par tous qui ou quoi
c'est vraiment un mec bienveillant et
suite à ces évènements scott a décidé
quelques mois plus tard d'arrêter ce taf
parce que c'était trop dangereux en fait
globalement tous les métiers comme ça où
tu dois surveiller qui est pas des trous
du cul qui vient de faire des trucs
interdits et donc des gens assez motivés
pour quand même venir tenter le truc
alors qu'ils savent que c'est interdit
et donc des gens potentiellement
dangereux gros respect ça me terrifie
alors la troisième histoire c'est celle
de samy et il ya une mécanique folle
dedans sami est américain et il aime la
chasse il aime la chasse au sanglier
plus particulièrement il explique que le
ministère de la pêche et de la faune en
cadre évidemment énormément la chasse
mais que concernant la chasse au
sanglier il ya beaucoup moins de règles
puisque les sangliers représenterait
dans pas mal d'endroits un problème
d'ordre écologique et les femelles
peuvent avoir jusqu'à deux portées par
an qui peuvent donner chacune jusqu'à
dix naissances bref pourquoi il explique
sa famille parce qu'il vient d'acheter
une lunettes à vision nocturne et que le
seul truc que tu as le droit de chasser
avec cette lunette c'est le sanglier un
soir et décide donc d'aller tester sa
toute nouvelle lunette et pour ça il se
rend deux nuits dans une zone parsemée
de sangliers ils arrivent sur les lieux
et puis commence à regarder au loin et
là il est déçu parce que pendant une
heure il se passe rien il ya très peu
d'activités animal alors même si il a le
droit la de tirer que sur des sangliers
il a vu ni cern il a pas ni hibou
nikolov bref à l'endroit où il se trouve
là dans cette forêt il ya l'air d'avoir
aucune activité animal autour de lui
sauf que l'endroit où ils se trouvent il
y est déjà allé deux jours et deux jours
il ya plein d'animaux le temps passe et
là ça fait quand même bientôt quatre
heures que samy est posté à regarder
dans sa lunette et qui a rien quoi c'est
à dire qu'il sait même pas capable sont
glissés qui a pas un seul être vivant
aux alentours il n'a pas le temps de
trouver la réponse à ce dilemme qu'il
entend au loin des branches qui craquent
qui craquent sous poids de quelque chose
d'un être vivant et pointent en
direction de l'endroit devient de bruit
et là il voit la silhouette d'un petit
ours il ajuste sa portée isu main peu
dans la lune est hélas sa grande
surprise il découvre qu'en fait c'est
par nour ce qu'ils aiment voir c'est un
homme un homme voûtée qui est en train
de marcher à quatre pattes totalement
nue et puis pendant qu'ils observent
grâce à sa lunette sept hommes arrêtent
de marché mais c'est ma entre ses jambes
dans la terre et il se met à regarder en
l'air sami explique qu'il a l'impression
de voir un loup qui s'apprête à hurler
leur dans la lune sauf que là le mec va
pas hurler comme un loup il va hurler
avec une voix féminine au secours je
suis perdu ces sorties de la bouche du
mac à quatre pattes qui voit dans sa
lunette sam il est complètement tétanisé
il est figé il ose pas bougé un muscle
se dit mais c'est quoi ce bordel c'est
un animal c'est un humain c'est une
femme qui s'est perdue il comprend plus
rien et pendant qu'ils se posent des
milliards de questions il entend de
nouveau la personne criait au loin et il
entend cette fois dire au secours s'il
vous plaît je ne peux pas marcher et
c'est là que ça me comprend qu'il est
potentiellement en danger il l'a vu
marcher cette personne et elle marchait
très bien elle se déplaçait tellement
bien cette personne qui l'a pris pour un
ours carrément et comprend donc que si
elle ment sur sa capacité à se déplacer
c'est qu'elle a des intentions
probablement malveillantes sami et
choqué il n'a pas du tout envie de
confronter cette personne il n'a pas du
tout envie qu'elle sache qu'il est là du
coup il sort l'oeil de sa lunette pour
récupérer ses affaires et se casser et
puis avant de partir il regardera
lunettes de son fusil voir si la
personne n'a bougé et en regardant dans
sa lunette à sa grande surprise la
personne n'a pas bougé par contre à
noaillan crucial elles regardent droit
dans sa direction sami estime que la
personne qu'il regarde dans sa lunette
se trouve à 150 mètres de lui et sami se
chie dessus c'est donc tout
naturellement qui va hurler à cette
personne va te faire et au moment
où ils crise à la personne se lève elle
se tient maintenant debout droite comme
un humain il estime à vue de lunettes
qu'elle fait au moins 1 mètre 90 hélas
cette personne se met à marcher droit
dans la direction de sa vie en voyant ça
ça a mis son coeur s'arrête clairement
élèves sont fusillés tirs en l'air pour
faire fuir le mec et au moment où il
tire le mec s'arrête et se remet tout de
suite à quatre pattes sami leur crie
dessus et cette fois il lui dit va-t-en
je veux pas de problèmes et la loma cap
at se met à taper un sprint et s'enfonce
dans la forêt sami ne le voit plus dans
ses lunettes et là il se dit bon je vais
pas traîner ici il tire une autre balle
en l'air et étape un sprint jusqu'à sa
voiture et pendant qu'ils courent il
entend au loin ce qui ressemble soit des
hurlements soit des reer ou un mélange
des deux quoi qu'il en soit ils arrivent
à atteindre sa voiture et étape la
pointe de sa vie jusqu'à chez lui donc
les gars il est clair que les windigo
existe et que ce genre asami a aperçu
owens i go en plein milieu de la plus
tard fort et wendy go qui a voulu lui
tendre un piège en se faisant passer
pour une femme en détresse pas capable
de marcher et perdu au milieu de la
forêt est-ce qu'on est bon sur cette
rencontre moi je vous dis je vais plus
aller en forêt pendant un an la presse
et histoire nation je suis désolé mon
frérot mais il ya des wanna go c'est pas
ma faute messieurs dames 4e cette
quatrième histoire c'est celle de peter
peter et québécois bio pour québécois et
ça a son importance parce que comme vous
le savez au québec il fait nuit beaucoup
plus tôt et surtout il neige beaucoup
l'histoire que twitter nous raconte a
donc eu lieu il ya pas mal d'années et à
l'époque il a 9 ans peter habite pas
loin de son école primaire il a une
grande soeur avec laquelle il fait très
souvent le trajet jusqu'à l'école aller
retour mais ce jour là à cause d'une
activité parascolaire qui a duré plus
longtemps que prévu et rentre tout seul
chez lui de l'école aux alentours de
17h30 il ya 20 cm de neige qui était
annoncée ce jour là autant vous dire
qu'on était sur une belle tempête de
neige après dix minutes a marché dans le
froid une visibilité quasi nulle peter
arrive enfin au coin de sa rue ils sont
une mince posée sur son épaule et
tourner la tête et il voit un homme
habillé en noir lui demander de l'aide
pour aller déblayer sa voiture dans sa
cour arrière évidemment peter c'est
qu'il faut toujours se méfier des
inconnus surtout quand il invite mais
l'homme insisté lui propose 10 dollars
en échange de son aide et la peter se
confie nous dit bombard effectivement
j'ai toujours été très vénale du coup
suite à cette proposition bas j'ai
accepté d'aller aider ce mec a déblayé
sa voiture l'homme invitent peter a
passé la porte qui mène soit disant à sa
cour arrière et après l'avoir franchi
peter constate que ya pas de voiture et
au moment il comprend qu'il ya pas de
voiture il entend la porte derrière lui
se refermer et l'homme lui propose
d'aller boire un chocolat chaud à
l'intérieur de sa maison peter
évidemment est terrifié il se retourne
il regarde l'homme et lui dit écoute en
fait je dois vraiment rentrer mes
parents m'attendent hélas les événements
prennent une tournure dramatique
l'homme fait trois pas arrive au niveau
de peter et lui met une énorme gifle et
puis commence à l'engueuler commence à
lui dire bah alors tes parents et ont
pas appris les bonnes manières toit et
d'un coup il change de tous il sourit
hélène voix douce et lui dit je vais
t'apprendre mois les bonnes manières il
prend ensuite peter par le bras et il
amène vers la porte de sa maison sauf
que peter il fait ce que n'importe quel
enfant aurait fait à sa place il se
débat dans tous les sens et il hurle de
toutes ses forces dans l'action à force
de bouger dans tous les sens il réussi à
se libérer et là il se dit bon comment
je m'enfuis est effectivement peter hill
et à oméga tenus contre le froid c'est à
dire que tu es patrie mobilité pas très
agile tu peux pas trop courir fins c'est
compliqué pour lui de s'enfuir et en
tournant la tête et voit que le mec
n'est plus à côté de la porte de sa
maison mais qu'il est juste à côté lui
avec une pelle dans les mains et ils
essaient de lui mettre un coup dans les
jambes avec l'appel peter réussi à
franchir la clôture ce qui fait qu'il a
atterri dans la cour arrière du voisin
du mec et à partir de là il emprunte la
ruelle adjacente et y tape le sprint de
sa vie dans la neige jusqu'à chez lui
une minute plus tard il atteint enfin la
porte arrière de sa maison et en
arrivant cette porte il l'a pourri et la
bourrine parce qu'il sait que sa soeur
est déjà rentré à la maison en revanche
il ne sait pas si le mec qui a voulu le
mettre un coup de pelle l'a suivi ou non
heureusement la soeur de peter lui ouvre
la porte après seulement quelques
secondes immédiatement il fond en larmes
sa soeur comprend pas ce qui se passe
elle va réveiller son père et le père de
peter ça ne fait pas du tout rire car
inconnu voulu frapper son fils kidnappé
en apprenant ce qui vient de se passer
il s'habille et prend un couteau et
demande à peter où est la maison en
question son père part revient plus tard
avec la police la police prend la
déposition peeters et à partir de là lui
n'a plus jamais eu une nouvelle idée
enquêteurs ni de ses parents pourquoi
parce qu'en fait c'est un truc qui l'a
profondément traumatisé à tel point que
il n'est plus allé à l'école de l'année
après avoir vécu ça il a continué sa
scolarité à domicile
il ne voulait plus sortir de chez lui il
avait trop peur et puis à la fin de
l'année pour d'autres raisons la famille
a déménagé et ce n'est que dix ans après
qui va avoir des news que son père va
oser enfin lui en parler en fait ce
jour-là son père arrive devant la maison
en question est la porte d'entrée était
entrouverte il aperçoit donc l'intérieur
de la maison et là dedans tout est
sombre et en désordre l'agresseur de
peter a en fait pris la fuite bonne
nouvelle les policiers les enquêteurs
finissent par retrouver l'homme et par
l'arrêté il s'agit en fait d'un homme
qui avait déjà été incarcéré pour
séquestration et agression d'enfants
aussi pour détention de pédopornographie
et qu'il avait été remis en liberté
conditionnelle pour bonne conduite grâce
aux témoignages de peter il est donc
retourné en prison il a vu sa peine est
radicalement augmenté peter a donc
vraiment échappé à un truc ignoble ce
jour là alors qu'il n'avait que neuf ans
ça lui a quand même valu un très très
gros traumatisme et ça nous rappelle que
ces trucs de kidnapping c'est réel ça
existe et comme j'ai déjà raconté dans
une vidéo j'avais failli moi même me
faire kidnapper par des mecs en voiture
exactement comme peter quand j'allais à
l'école primaire et c'est vrai que si on
n'a pas été sensibilisés à ce sujet à un
jeune âge pas malheureusement sa pesée
de sa pelouse à 8h je suis ravi que tu
as et bien je suis ravi que tu es en
jambes et cette clôture comme un athlète
olympique ce jour là et on est ravi que
grâce à toi il soit retourné en prison
et qu'il n'ait pas pu faire du mal à qui
que ce soit d'autre beau gosse peter
messieurs dames je vais acheter mon
casque pour cette dernière histoire oui
c'est déjà la dernière histoire la
dernière histoire c'est celle de
nathalie elle parle d'un truc d'amitié
toxiques qui moi me glace le sang
l'histoire de nathalie et eu lieu il ya
pas mal d'années en 2008 et à l'époque
on parle à ses amis via msn oh oui
nathalie à ce moment là est très pote
avec une fille qui s'appelle tania c'est
sa meilleure pote mais il ya vraiment un
truc fusionnelle entre elles c'est à
dire qu'elles passent leur journée à
discuter à l'école et quand elles
rentrent le soir elle passe une bonne
partie de la soirée de leur nuit à
discuter encore sur msn un soir tania et
nathalie parle de mec abbas el haj un
préadolescent c'est là où tu commences à
te poser des questions quand même tania
expliqué nathalie qu'elle aurait entendu
dire que marc un élève de la classe de
nathalie les mre fortement et amiens en
tant que meilleur pote a réussi à voir
son adresse msn et elle ne la lui donne
le soir qui suit nathalie reçoit un
message de marquis boy 99 il l'a
acceptée sur msn et il vient de lui
envoyer un message waouh imaginer à
quelle vitesse balle coeur de nathalie à
ce moment là il lui envoie un oeil elle
lui envoie en retour un oeil ça commence
comme ça vous savez comment ça finit ils
ont parlé toute la nuit ils ont parlé de
leur journée de l'école des groupes de
musique qu'ils aiment bref des
discussions classique de jeunes de 11
ans et nathalie est au paradis on peut
le dire a répliqué parce que c'est la
première fois qu'elle plaît un garçon a
et à ce moment là elle a tellement peu
d'estimé d'elle même qu'elle est
complètement flatté qu'un mec lui parle
tout simplement et elle développe tout
de suite des sentiments très forts pour
lui et en plus marquée des styles et
gens qui jouent au football il est
extravertie bref c'est un peu le cliché
du beau gosse de ta classe quand tu es
au collège ils vont se parler très
souvent il ya une complicité de fou
entre deux mais petit bémol les
conversations n'ont lieu que sur msn
c'est à dire que marc et nathalie n'ont
jamais osé s'appelait probablement par
timidité et au collège pareil ici niort
ils vont pas trop l'un vers l'autre bref
s'ils veulent peut-être tout simplement
pas que les gens sachent qui se passe un
truc entre mais un jour malgré la
timidité malgré stress malgré tout
nathalie elle a envie de franchir le pas
et prend son courage à deux mains elle
va voir marc elle commence à lui parler
et marc a juste l'air confus comme s'il
n'avait jamais eu une conversation avec
elle et efficace immédiatement d'un
thalys dit ça lui ressemble pas le mec
est méga extraverti il est trop marrant
bref elle vit très mal ce qui vient de
se passer son ego est brisé et surtout
elle comprend pas elle se sent trahie
elle dit mais pourquoi évidemment elle a
quand même besoin d'en parler elle le
vit mal et donc qui d'autre que tania
tania et daniel comprend pas elle se dit
mais attend on marque ce bâtard elle va
même jusqu'à lui dire qu'elle va le
confronter pendant son cours de musique
l'après midi parce que c'est vraiment
pas cool ce qu'il a fait et ça
fonctionne parce que le soir en rentrant
chez elle nathalie reçoit un message de
marque qui lui dit je suis désolé pour
aujourd'hui c'est juste qu'en ce moment
j'ai des problèmes de famille et
j'arrivais pas à gérer ce truc là avec
toi à l'école c'était trop nouveau trop
brusque ans pour moi mais désolé il
vient s'excuser nathalie et rassurer
immédiatement allé nouveau amoureuse
elle se dit même qu'en vrai avoir une
relation juste virtuel avec lui ça lui
va parce que l on tire trop de trucs
positifs et ça lui fait vraiment du bien
un mois passent on est le 31 mars 2009
nathalie reçoit un message de marque qui
lui dit écoute j'ai un truc très
important à dire demain alors évidemment
elle se chie dessus ça fout la pression
ce genre de message ce 31 mars nathalie
elle en parle à sa mère elle en parle
attagniant elle leur dit mais qu'est ce
que ça peut être et les deux lui dise
écoute tu vas voir on est le 1er avril
2009 il est 19h et nathalie reçoit enfin
un message de marque elle reçoit une
photo et c'est pas une photo de marque
c'est une photo de tania et sur cette
photo tania elle tient une pancarte et
sur cette pancarte ya écrit joyeux
poisson d'avril xd
oui oui depuis des mois et des mois et
des mois nathalie pense parlé à marc
dont elle est folle amoureuse mais en
réalité elle parle attagniant alors que
c'est tania qui avait présenté soit
disant marque à nathalie italien aurait
en fait été complètement jalouse de la
réussite scolaire de nathalie et elle
aurait donc prétendu être quelqu'un
d'autre ce fameux marque pour jouer avec
ses sentiments et lui faire du mal est à
l'alluré pour tout simplement qu'elle
est trop bête d'avoir pensé qu'elle
parlait vraiment un marque et qu'elle
est trop bête de jamais avoir osé lui
demander son numéro parce qu'elle aurait
tout de suite su que c'était pas marc
bref par les sept mois de suite à ta
meilleur pote en prétendant est un mec
en creux sur elle pour un poisson
d'avril c'est beaucoup ça n'existe pas
ce n'est pas une blague pendant les mois
qui suivent tania va tout tenter de
culpabiliser nathalie d'en but de
redevenir sont m au fil de ces mois et
lui fait des tas de dinguerie mais la
plus notable est la suivante tania lui
envoie un message dans lequel il lui
explique que sa mère est décédée dans un
horrible accident de voiture suite à la
violence de l'accident son corps aurait
même été démontrée nathalie est touché
d'autant plus qu'elle avait vu plusieurs
fois la mère de tania et que c'était
quelqu'un de profondément sympa avec m
et ça la touche tellement qu'elle se
remet à parler à tania et à lui apporter
son soutien et a rejoué à lui demande
quand sont les funérailles de sa maman
et à ce message tania va lui répond
qu'elle est trop conne elle est trop
conne de croire que sa mère est morte
dans un accident de voiture et qu'elle a
été démembré elle plaisante c'était une
blague voilà le genre de dan gris que
nathalie va subir la part de tania
pendant plusieurs mois c'est horrible
par la suite tania se rapproche d'une
fille qui s'appelle kelly elles
deviennent très copines toutes les deux
et nathalie elle n'avait qu'une seule
amie c'était à venir c'est à dire que
depuis qu'ils avaient ces histoires là
avec ta dire à l'école elle est tout
seul nat et le comportement de tania
envers nathalie baye de plus en plus
violents carrément ma montagne et
envoient des messages à nathalie en lui
disant tu devrais te suicider personnes
thème et ce harcèlement parce que c'est
du harcèlement il va durer pendant
quatre ans mais un jour nathalie reçoit
un énième message de tania et là c'en
est trop elles ont peu plus elle en
parle enfin à sa mère sa mère appelle
immédiatement la police et leur
expliquer la situation la police va
appeler la mère de tania et la mère de
tania va interdire à cette dernière de
parler à nathalie et peu à peu nathalie
réussi grâce à son sang froid et à ses
nouveaux amis à sortir un peu de la
situation rythme dans laquelle elle
était tania et kelly au moins en moins
de pouvoir et d'influencé sur elle et
nathalie va finir sa scolarité en étant
plutôt heureuse et aujourd'hui elle a 22
ans elle a deux diplômes là en
psychologie et là en histoire bref elle
s'en est complètement sortie même si ça
l'a marqué et que rien qu'en écrivant ce
texte elle lui rappelle des trucs très
dur qui font partie de son histoire et
l'est sur lesquels elle peut pas tirer
un trait c'est normal et je trouve son
histoire un méga touchante parce que le
harcèlement et le cyber harcèlement sont
encore des trucs très présent dans la
société moi j'ai pas a subi des
harcèlements quand j'étais à l'école
mais je trouve ça vraiment choquant ce
qu'elle a vécu quoi ta meilleur pote qui
se fait passer pour un faux crush
pendant sept mois fin même moi qui suis
au courant qu'il ya beaucoup de
harcèlement je pensais pas sa possible
enfin bref j'ai nathalie c'était une
histoire d'amitié toxiques on n'en avait
jamais eu dans laisserait d'horreur et
je trouve que effectivement ça
totalement sa place ici parce que c'est
horrible messieurs dames c'est la fin de
ce serait d'horreur spécial blick et pas
halloween en revanche la vidéo spéciale
halloween sort le 31 octobre jour
d'halloween j'espère aussi que celle-ci
vous a plu en acier beaucoup varier les
histoires pour moi tout est assez ouf la
danse qu'on vient de raconter en tout
cas merci pour tous les retours que j'ai
tout le temps sur lui serait de voir
vous adorez particulièrement ce format
ce qui a pour effet de nous foute une
pression parce que j'espère qu'il
continuera de vous plaire donc j'essaie
de varier un peu les histoires et tout
donc je suis pas prêt d'arrêter format
mais j'aimerais bien le faire évoluer
peut-être ou faire des vidéos je cible
une seule mes gars de grosses histoires
désolé d'avoir été chiant avec la bd
mais je suis vraiment très très fier de
ce projet j'ai vraiment hâte d'avoir vos
retours sur les histoires sur tout mais
c'est terrible ce qui est des projets où
il ya tellement de gens qui ont bossé
sur une tellement longue période c'est
tellement de stress a lancé et tout que
on a envie que ça plaise quoi bref a
très vite tout le monde plein de bisous
chose je vous jure je vais regarder un
dessin animé cinq histoires c'est trop
c'est pour ça qu'on fait trois
d'habitude 5 c'est trop de charge
mentale
[Musique]